ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman i want to start today with what
is happening
in cuba which is both uh horrifying and
it's fascinating it's politically
relevant and of course we're
all globally as we'll talk about in a
moment
every country in some way dealing with
not just coronavirus generally but also
this resurgence of the virus despite
vaccinations starting to roll out
because of the very contagious delta
variant
all of this relates to what's going on
in cuba so let's start there
a very good article in the bbc
explaining generally speaking what's
happening in cuba
right now if you've not been following
it there are essentially
three issues here that are leading to
massive
protests in cuba first is
as is written here the coronavirus
crisis
the protests the bbc rights appear to be
the result of societal
exhaustion stemming from acute economic
and health crises
the pandemic and economic measures taken
by the government have made life in cuba
increasingly difficult
the pand the island which had kept the
pandemic under control in 2020 has seen
infections explode in recent week weeks
we'll look at those numbers
momentarily but records in terms of
daily infections
in terms of deaths the health care
system on the brink
of collapse that is one piece of it and
the hashtag
sos cuba has been trending on twitter
uh this is one of the you know one of
the areas that
we've seen open slightly in cuba is that
of
internet access and now that leading to
the sos cuba hashtag which the
government is not
thrilled with and we will talk about
that in a moment number two
the economic situation tourism is
uh one of the main engines for the cuban
economy
almost completely paralyzed as a result
of the coronavirus pandemic
in addition cuba is seeing inflation
blackouts food shortages as well as
shortages of medicine and basic products
those aren't new issues
but they have been particularly worse
lately at the beginning of the year the
government proposed a new package of
economic reforms that while increasing
wages triggered a spike in prices
prices economists such as pavel vidal
from the pontificia
caveriana university of cali in colombia
estimate prices could rise between 500
and 900 percent in the next few months
starting to look
like my birth country of argentina from
the standpoint of
inflation and then number three
internet access before sunday the
largest protest cuba had seen since the
start of castro's communist revolution
took place in august of 94. many cubans
had no idea what happened because of
lack of internet access
thirty years on the scenario is
different under the presidency of raul
castro cuba has liberalized uh taken
some liberalizing steps
which increased internet connectivity
and as i mentioned earlier as a result
of that
cubans have been using social networks
to express dissatisfaction with the
government
mainly young people now have access to
facebook twitter and
instagram and this platform uh was these
platforms were used
to organize the protests so
then we look at well what is the u.s
perspective
on this because the us has had crippling
sanctions on cuba
for a very long time sanctions that
while i am not a communist
and i am against the way that uh
cuba has operated with no open elections
for decades
despite promises made during the 1950s
and 60s i'm completely against that i
also recognized the total hypocrisy
of the u.s saying well we can't
tacitly endorse the way cuba is run and
so we're putting sanctions on them
and yet we have the relationship we have
with saudi arabia and many other
countries okay so i've talked about that
before
joe biden yesterday during a press event
bringing up
the cuban protests and saying the u.s
stands with the people of cuba take a
look at this
okay folks i want to start by
recognizing remarkable protesters
taking place in cuba the cuban people
demanding their freedom from an
authoritarian regime
and i don't think we've seen anything
like this protest
uh in a long long time if quite frankly
ever
the united states stands firmly with the
people of cuba
as they assert their universal rights
and we call on the government
government cuba to refrain from violence
their attempts to silence the voice of
the people of cuba and we're also
closely following the developments in
haiti
so this is a complicated issue
um and anybody you know you've got
a lot of very right-wing cubans
in florida for example who love trump
and who are saying uh we need to
continue crushing the cuban government
and punishing it
we're just punishing the people if we do
that on the other hand
we also have to recognize that part of
why things are the way they are
in cuba is because of american policy
towards cuba
for decades and so anybody who wants to
sort of
pigeonhole me on this issue and say well
but so david are you for or against or
what you put
no we have to recognize that on the one
hand
the u.s has had a major role in keeping
things
worse in cuba than they could otherwise
be
we should be easing the sanctions that
trump put in remember that
barack obama eased some sanctions donald
trump came in
and reinstituted a lot of those
sanctions and although joe biden is on
the one hand saying we're with the cuban
people
the very sanctions that joe biden has
not eased that were put back in place by
donald trump
are part of why things are so bad at the
same time
i have been unquestionably against the
authoritarian regime in cuba
all of this time but we must recognize
that the us is friendly with many
authoritarian regimes
and so singling out cuba has been a
hypocrisy for decades obviously my main
concern
is the cuban people and um these are
massive and significant protests because
of the internet access
this may be we're seeing the repression
from the police state of cuba
and we're getting reports of you know
officers on every corner
and any everything you can imagine
would go on is going on at the same time
we can't ignore the u.s role
in uh cuba being at least partially the
way that it is now
we'll see over the next 48 hours the
direction that the government responds
to the protest is going to take
i am repulsed today
truly repulsed by having to do this
story
but we are seeing a massive coveted
resurgence right now
which is leading to some countries in
stating health passes
new vaccine requirements speculative
third
vaccine doses and much much more and
it's all because we aren't vaccinating
enough people
in some parts of the world because they
don't yet have vaccines
in the united states because we have so
many ignorant anti-vaxxers
here in the united states daily cases
are now up listen to this
69 69
cases up in the united states globally
cases are now up 24 what is happening
the delta variant combined with not
enough vaccination
okay the delta variant is about 60
percent more contagious than the
original variant
it's spreading yes mostly among
unvaccinated people
that is a testament to the effectiveness
of the vaccines but it's not exclusively
among
the unvaccinated because the vaccines
aren't 100 effective
and the vaccines were not designed
specifically to be tailored to the delta
variant
and right now as many people in the
united states continue to refuse to get
vaccinated
things are increasingly pointed to a
very ugly fall of 2021.
i am fully expecting at this point you
know three months ago i said
in the fall um as we
get into flu season i would be fine with
saying hey we've got to go back to masks
at the grocery store and stuff like that
at this point i'm fully expecting that
masks are coming back on in the fall
in a widespread manner unless people
really go out and get vaccinated right
now now as a result
look at what's going on around the world
remember much of the world doesn't yet
have access to vaccines like we have in
the us
in france the president emmanuel macron
is putting in place new health rules
including the eu digital covet
certificate some people call this the
health pass
and it's going to be mandatory if you
want to go to any cultural venue
if you want to go to the movies you will
have to be using the health pass
starting in august the health pass will
be mandatory to go to cafes
shops and restaurants as well as trains
and planes among other places
france is also going to require health
care workers
be vaccinated if they want to continue
working around patients
and in health care settings in israel
one of the most
vaccinated countries in the world they
are now starting
third doses of the pfizer vaccine for
the most
at risk adults why it's relatively
speculative there's the idea
that a third dose might provide more
protection
particularly for at-risk folks it is not
something that the who says
is indicated the who says let's keep
giving first
doses to completely unvaccinated people
but desperation is growing as even
israel is seeing okay it's a very little
increase in cases
israel is so highly vaccinated that it's
not a big increase
but there are more breakthrough cases
happening in israel as well as delta
variant cases
among people who have not been
vaccinated tennessee
has now fired its top vaccine official
because covid19 is showing
signs of massive spread in tennessee
california cases are now up 181
compared to the previous week so is
there any good news
the good news continues to be we have a
tool that works really well against the
delta variant if we all use it
and when a vaccinated person does get
infected
they are overwhelmingly completely
asymptomatic
most breakthrough vaccinated infections
are asymptomatic
not all and there are vaccinated people
who have died
understand that now in the u.s officials
are saying
almost all recent hospitalizations and
deaths are unvaccinated people and
that's true
but not all and this is a community
effort this is a joint effort here
there are countries that as they get
access to the vaccine
are already seeing way more interest in
getting it than we've seen in the united
states look at canada for example
canada got significant vaccine access
much later than the united states
and yet they're quickly catching up to
the u.s in terms of per capita
second doses so we need to deal with
anti-vaxxers
somehow and there are real concerns
about what things look like in the fall
if we don't do that just look at the
numbers these are not vague you know
it's so easy to hear these headlines oh
it's more contagious
oh some people don't want to get it and
have some
total disconnect from the fact that this
means people
develop symptoms that get so bad that
they go to the hospital and some of them
never come out
and it can mostly be avoided just by
going and getting vaccinated so
the fall um i understand that this is
becoming
overwhelmingly a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
but not completely and it's not as
simple as well
if you don't want to get vaccinated
you're the only one at risk that is not
the case
all right so as we head into the fall
we're going to continue
watching this by the way also as we head
into the fall
the david pakman show will be hitting
our 16
year anniversary our 16th anniversary i
believe is the right way to say it
and in fact on august 16th we will be
doing a one-day
16-year membership blowout i would love
for you to
join the ranks of membership to
celebrate our 16th year
um and really the start of the 17th year
right
uh okay and you can be notified of that
on august 16th just by getting on our
membership
on our newsletter you can sign up for it
at davidpakman.com
and let me know your thoughts about
where you see the pandemic
going in the fall by sending me a
message on twitter at deepakman
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back
ground news is one of the first things i
would use
to get my head in the game and prepare
myself for the interview because ground
news is a news source comparison
platform
that lets you compare how outlets from
the left right and center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how sources
with differing political biases are
covering a story
and it also shows you your news blind
spots stories that your side of the
political spectrum
may not have covered ground news can
help you build a well-crafted argument
for debating people you disagree with
or ground news can help you discover
something new
about your own perspective challenging
your own strongly held views on
political issues
be the most informed person in the room
download the free ground news app today
by going to ground.news
pacman our show is primarily
dependent on support from folks like you
if you listen to the show if you watch
the show
and you like it enough you don't have to
like it that much but if you like it
enough that you want it to continue
grab yourself a membership at
joinpacman.com we do a daily
extra show the bonus show world famous
and award-winning
bonus show every single day for our
members
and we have all sorts of other great
member benefits including a commercial
free audio feed of the show every day
a commercial free video feed of the show
every day and more
uh sign up at joinpakman.com take a
discount if you want the coupon code
better21 saving you a pretty penny
as the kids say these days this you are
not going to believe or maybe you are
and like maybe that's the problem that
it's so predictable
republicans are now really really
concerned about
wait for it discrimination now you might
say well discrimination against who is
is it they now care about discrimination
against racial minorities which they
previously said doesn't happen
nope that's not it does the right now
care about discrimination against the
poor
nope nope nope they're still okay
criminalizing poverty in many cities and
states
are they now worried about
discrimination against women no
anti-semitism are they ready to finally
say we can't have
no it's not that either republicans are
now really concerned about
discrimination against
unvaccinated people choosing
not to get vaccinated against the covid
virus
we are now seeing state republican
lawmakers across the country
propose and advocate for new bills one
of which is already law
which would protect unvaccinated people
in the way
that people are already protected based
on race gender
and religion and even going beyond the
way many states protect folks on the
basis
of sexual orientation or gender identity
think about that it is still legal to
discriminate against people based on
sexual orientation real or perceived
gender identity real or perceived in
more than 20 states
you can fire people or say you can't
do business at my store based on
sexual orientation and gender identity
in more than 20 states but suddenly
republicans want to protect
anti-vaxxers in the same way that race
and religion are protected what a
country we live in
the way these bills would work if they
become law and one of them
has become law is that they would ban
businesses from saying
if you want to work here in person
you've got to be vaccinated businesses
would be banned from doing that
if these bills become law or businesses
wouldn't be allowed to say you have to
be vaccinated
to be a customer of our business we've
already seen vaccinated and unvaccinated
sections
at some sporting uh venues sporting
event facilities
we've already seen republicans call
vaccination programs and masks
like nazism like apartheid
like the holocaust and now they're
saying
treat being against the vaccine just
like we treat
being black or being christian under the
law
now consider something particularly
absurd about this
one of the reasons that republicans
often don't want
sexual orientation protected in the same
way
that uh race is protected or religion is
protected is they say well
sexual orientation is a choice we don't
protect just choices that people make
or everybody's straight some people
choose
to live a gay life now this is of course
not true
it's not true but if you were to grant
that to them
and say okay your principle is you only
want to protect
inherent traits and you don't consider
sexual orientation
inherent you're of the mindset that
people choose their sexual orientation
all right
being vaccinated is a choice being
vaccinated is unquestionably something
you can control
you can't control whether you're black
white or asian you can't control whether
you have a disability
you can't control your age you can't
control the country you were born in
vaccination is a choice and you can
control it and it's republicans who have
been saying
we don't protect things that are choices
under the law now i would go even
further because i've said
before there are good arguments that
religion should not be protected as a
class
because it's a choice now there are
people who will say well
kinda i mean you're brought up in a
religion so it's not totally like i mean
yeah you can leave the religion but
you're kind of born into it
because your family's religion is what's
at least initially passed on to you
but or you might say well yeah the thing
about religion even though it's a choice
is the country is is really
was based on the concept of religious
freedom either to be whatever religion
you want or not to be any
and so there's something special about
religion in terms of the founding of the
country and thus it should be protected
however you assess religion and it being
a choice
vaccination is unquestionably uh more of
a choice
so why should it be protected and these
are the same folks who say businesses
shouldn't be regulated
let them do what they want except if
what they want is to say hey
if you choose not to get a vaccine you
can't work here or maybe you can't shop
here oh no that's too much all of a
sudden for these very same republicans
we need to ban
that and by banning that what we're
saying is impose
more regulation on businesses they say
they're against business regulation
this is very heavy-handed business
regulation so it's a total hypocrisy
it's another double standard but where
it is consistent it's that it's another
way
for republicans to play the victim they
are the victims as told
by their imaginary narratives and the
reality
is that discriminating against people
based on actions
is how things should go in most cases
and what i mean by that is
when people behave in a way that's
antisocial
or dangerous to public health or
whatever
shouldn't businesses be able to say we
will sanction those individuals not
because of who they
are but because of what they've chosen
to do
and one such sanctioning is if you're
not vaccinated you can't shop here you
can't work here because you're a risk to
the people that are here
basically the principle that actually is
at play is if it affects them
it's discrimination as they see it and
then you need regulation to stop it
truly vile people and while
fortunately at the federal level this
anti-vaxx crusade isn't getting much
oxygen
they are having some success at the
state level one of these bills has
already become law
and we have to really be on guard for it
because they are pushing hard
and they already have one victory it's
horrible horrible stuff the world sees
this and they say
sirs what are you doing what are you
doing
and i don't have the answer i'm as
embarrassed by it
as many around the world are all right
guys it is time
to have a conversation that i predict
many in the audience are not going to
like i have seen this trend
over the last few days as i and others
have been covering cpac
the republican conference over the
weekend and the trend is people saying
hey
progressives trump is over forget about
trump don't talk about trump don't talk
about cpac never mention donald trump
again
he lost he's gone he's irrelevant now i
must operate in reality and the reality
right now
is that there are two major political
parties in the united states one of them
is the republican party
and their candidate donald trump
received 74 million votes in 2020.
that very same donald trump easily
crushed
everyone in the cpac straw poll from
this weekend
which we looked at yesterday the numbers
are not even close
now i know a lot of people want to wish
or do wish
donald trump was irrelevant but no one
other than trumpian republican governor
ron desantis is even polling more than
one percent right now in the cpac straw
poll as you can see
in the results that we have on screen
donald trump
pulled 70 in the cpac straw poll
ron desantis was at 21 and then you've
got a bunch of one percenters
rand paul nikki haley ted cruz and
tucker carlson
of those people i think only tucker
carlson even has a shot
at significantly growing his level of
support tucker carlson decided
i want to grow my level of support and
maybe look at being the republican
nominee
partially because of his media platform
so i wish trump weren't relevant
but ignoring him won't make him
irrelevant trump is in complete and
total control of the republican party he
owns the republican party right now
we could wish him uh uh we we could wish
that he'd be irrelevant but he's not
and much the same way that not paying
attention in 2016
is partially what led him to winning the
republican primary and subsequently
becoming president of the united states
pretending that this guy doesn't have
an incredibly devout fervent feverish
following
could potentially lead to the exact same
thing in 2024 and there's people already
emailing me saying they don't want to
hear it
i was one of the people that made this
mistake in 2015 and 2016. i
overestimated the intelligence of the
republican electorate
when you overestimate their intelligence
you get crushed and
i never thought they would be so
ignorant that they would make trump
their nominee but they did
and then many on the left myself
included didn't really take the threat
of trump seriously in the general
election
and next thing you know he's president
of the united states he's mishandling
covid he's humiliating us globally
and the rest is history now trump won by
very few votes in a few states in 2016.
he lost by slightly more
in 2020 but again it was not that many
votes and not that many states
that pushed the electoral victory to joe
biden the popular vote victory of course
biden ran away with
and this level of devotion from the
republican party
who were activated by imaginary threats
of joe biden's communism
and joe biden's marxism and kamala
harris's socialism
they are ripe for crushing democrats in
2022 and 2024.
now political scientist rachel
bittikoffer has been writing about this
quite a bit she feels
people aren't paying enough attention
we're going to speak to rachel
i believe it's on thursday this week and
that's assuming she's fully recovered
from her appendicitis she's been
tweeting about it we wish her well
uh and she is very concerned about this
as well
i understand being sick of trump and
being completely embarrassed that he's
still
getting this adulation and support from
the republican party
but this guy is very much in control
right now
is it sad that these are the people
leading the cpac straw poll right now
of course it's sad is it globally
humiliating
that after everything we've suffered
including i mean the deadly
mismanagement of the covid pandemic that
trump
did is it globally humiliating that he's
polling 70
of the cpac straw poll of course it is
of course it is it's a global
humiliation without a doubt
but this is what it is and he may win
and we don't gain anything by ignoring
it and in fact
i think we're more at risk of that
happening if we just pretend
that trump is a bygone at this point in
time if you disagree with me
i want to hear from you but it can't be
a personal attack guys it really can't
uh if you if you believe that the left
ignoring trump would make a difference
we disagree but i'm open to hearing why
and we'll have more about
this particular story on our instagram
if you're not following the david pakman
show on instagram at this point i don't
know what you're doing crossword puzzles
maybe
which are fun by the way but instagram
is cool too follow us on instagram
at david pakman show we will take a
quick break and be back with much more
right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming
a member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive of every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount joinpakman.com
so we had today something happen which
happens every couple of months which is
at the very very last second
a guest uh no shows cancels on us
and that's a really sad thing or happy
depending on your perspective because
instead we'll get to hear from a few
people
in our audience right now via discord
the discord is at davidpakman.com
slash discord it's a great discord it's
a good
discord and we love it let's go first
just to see what's on folks minds let's
go to desmond from
south carolina desmond you were on the
air what's going on
hello can you hear me yes i can how's it
going david uh
i really appreciate your show haven't
tuned in
recently but um let me catch my breath
please all right um
so uh i've been noticing a lot with uh
conservative friends and family around
me gosh
it's weird you're running a marathon
there desmond
no i mean uh you know this is the first
time for me so gotcha gotcha
you're doing great i appreciate it
uh i've i went out to eat with my
grandma no conservative
and we were noticing how here in south
carolina there's a lot of places that
are
they're like hiring and um and some
places are like
uh my grandma was saying oh it's because
all these people are too lazy because uh
they're getting all this welfare
right unemployment and it just made me
it triggered
a thing of me that made me realize well
you know an economics class
this is kind of like a perfect moment to
raise minimum wage
and uh i just don't get why
conservatives aren't really talking
about that kind of basic economic stuff
well because a lot of people and listen
this is conservatives and liberals
everybody does this to some degree
um you identify a symptom
and then you say it's a symptom that
proves my politics are the right ones
so on the left people see hey there's
jobs remaining
unfilled it's because the wages are too
low raise the minimum wage
why because the left already wants to
raise the minimum wage on the other hand
the right
which doesn't want to raise the minimum
wage but wants to end welfare sees jobs
going unfilled and they say
well you've got to reduce welfare it's
too cushy
to stay at home you know the the truth
is we're in kind of a unique situation
right now because of the pandemic
where enhanced unemployment has made it
so that there are people who otherwise
would have no choice but to go and get a
job
who have been able to stay on
unemployment uh earning
a little more than they normally would
it's ending in september and as i've
said before
most people want to work most people
derive
meaning from being involved in something
and not just from sitting at home
any welfare system will have free riders
but if it's properly calibrated you
don't have to worry about that
i think this is going to resolve itself
in september october november
okay yeah i didn't know about um all
this ending in september
it was just interesting to me because i
noticed the unemployment number
getting slowly back down to that four
percent speed spot you know
but still like uh and i noticed other uh
states
actually when i looked into it are
actually resolving the issue
quite well where they easily uh
how do you say um they they just adapt
and they're like okay well we'll pay you
more but
there's a lot of places here even like
bigger businesses like um
dealerships are having troubles hiring
people because our you know our
minimum wage in south carolina is 7.25
so right yeah i think that this is going
to look very different in october okay i
appreciate it david all right thanks
desmond great call uh from south
carolina love it
let's go next to uh let's go to dave
from brooklyn
dave you were on the air hey david how
are you doing today i'm doing well
uh first thing i just want to thank you
because every day of my drive home from
work
i listen to you on youtube and um gets
me through the traffic
thank you i appreciate that um because i
have a new york city commute i'm a high
school teacher
in the bronx and i was wanting to get
your opinion about something because i
have been
frustrated for a few years now about the
lack of progress
that comes from the democratic party as
far as not a liberal-minded
person but i don't identify as democrat
anymore because we keep
i don't want to say losing it's the
wrong word but we keep
failing to pass meaningful progressive
legislation and i think a lot of it is
due to
complacency which i think comes back to
something you talk about a lot which is
lack of epistemological skills
and i wanted your opinion on i see that
as a teacher on both sides
and i just feel that because on the left
we get fed more accurate information
and our media sources are generally more
honest
therefore it doesn't get shown as much
as it does on the right
but i feel and this is what i want your
opinion on that because of our
failing education system in a lot of
ways we don't have
on the left we also lack a lot of those
epistemological skills and i'm afraid
that in the future
that may come to uh come to the
forefront
in a way that's more meaningful than it
does right now because on the left on
the right
on the right obviously it has come to
the forefront so
i think that you're not wrong that the
left sucker
suckers the left suffers from a lack
of epistemological skills too to some
degree
i don't think that's actually the source
of the left being ineffective in the
united states i think it's actually
a lack of rhetorical skill i think it's
it's uh and george lakoff has written
about this a lot
thomas frank has talked about this a lot
um we on the left when you
actually sit down and explain to people
not with a one-line slogan like if you
think about the one-line slogans
on abortion right hey the right is
pro-life
anything other than that is anti-life
that's really effective if you just go
with a one-liner
when you really sit down with people and
you explain stuff to them whether it's
about you know 10 years ago when you
really talked in detail about gay
marriage or you talk about health care
now or whatever the case may be
the country is much more on the left
than
the representatives that we elect so
what's the problem i don't think it's
lack of epistemological skill i think
it's lack of rhetorical
skill uh by the left combined with and
this is the other part that's important
lack of a willingness to sort of just
like
power through the way that the right
does it i mean what mitch mitch
mcconnell i find to be a vile
and and a moral person but he's
essentially a republican hero
not only for what he's been able to get
done for republicans over the last
decade but what he's been able to stop
democrats from doing like if you're a
republican you've got to love mitch
mcconnell for
what he's been able to do so i think
that the deficits for the democrats are
twofold
one lack of rhetorical skill in
uh talking about these issues in ways
that connect with voters
more and number two sort of a lack of
willingness to i'm not saying go low
in like commit crimes and do immoral
things but like
get down and really use whatever legal
legal methods we can use to actually
get things done i think those are the
issues may i ask a very short follow-up
question yeah of course
so if i'm understanding correctly so i
heard you talk about a couple days ago
on your show when you were talking about
you're showing clips of some trump
sports at cpac yeah and they were
talking about getting out and doing
local
local activism right i was wondering you
know
it was what you're talking about related
in any way to like the
fact the long-term effects of
gerrymandering and the drug war and
local
local voter populations and all that
kind of stuff
because that seems to be a place where
maybe in the long run democrats can
improve
absolutely and i guess that would be the
third piece which is
the right is just better at local
politics than the left it sucks that
that's the case but they're just
and by better i don't mean they're like
inherently better i don't mean they're
smarter
they're just doing it they're they're
carrying it out in a more effective way
and that includes school boards pta
city councillors etc uh yeah the
democrat i'm not a democrat either i
don't really care about the democratic
party as a party to the extent that we
can get some progressive things done
through the democratic party
great but i don't find it to be a
remotely competent political party
thank you so much david my pleasure all
right wow uh excellent
the these callers are basically as good
as the guests we were going to have so
really can't complain let's go next to
frumpus
from chicago frumpus you're on the air
frankfurt you're on the air how are you
i'm doing all right thank you um so i
saw
um some other countries are testing out
a four day work week have you heard of
that
yep we covered that on the bonus show
last week
okay um so i'm thinking that
some states in the u.s should try this
um and i've seen some justifications
stating things like well the five day
work week was based on
one family member and the typical
household staying home and taking care
of things the one person being the bread
winner so
i was just wondering what you were
thinking of the justifications to move
to a
four-day work week um i i've heard of
the productivity but i just
thought to get your comments on that
yeah what do you what do you when you
say states should try it do you mean
states should mandate that
businesses only have people work four
days or you mean like state employees
should do it
that's a that's a good distinction i was
thinking it was just a labor law
um within a certain state
yeah that's never going to happen but
let's let's put that aside i mean it's
not going to happen anytime soon let's
put that aside
sure here's why i think four four day a
week is is very interesting
there's a real difference between having
two days off
versus three days off a week and when
you have the three days off and you've
got that middle day where you were off
yesterday and you're off tomorrow
i think that psychologically there's a
massive benefit to that
and the benefit to that is that then
people are more
productive on the four days that they
are working
even if in total they're working
slightly fewer hours
we've sort of adopted this at the david
pakman show and that we film
our five shows each week in four days
so like we're we're not off on friday
but it's sort of like a
ketchup administrative work you know
everybody has the stuff we work on on
fridays but like
the core filming is all happening four
days a week and i know for me
psychologically
when we're done on thursday it's like oh
i'm not doing like a core
filming day friday saturday or sunday
that's really great and i think it makes
me significantly more productive monday
monday through thursday
if i had child care considerations i
think it would be
uh significantly uh more convenient
and also cheaper from the standpoint of
child care if i have three days
and then my significant other has three
days you know i think that there's
significant benefits there
uh but yeah i don't think there's
anything magical about a five day a week
work week and the the study
that we looked at last week on the bonus
show uh was very positive as far as that
goes
okay well god knows i could use another
day um thanks for taking my call i hope
producer pat's doing okay talk to you
later all right my pleasure thank you
very much
uh let's see why don't we speak next
to how about danny from los angeles
danny you're on the air
hey david uh can you hear me yes i can
uh it's a pleasure talking to you
you're giving me a lot of good talking
points okay one thank you for that
pleasure uh i
just have this uh question um we're
seeing uh
from what i'm reading and uh there's
like
people are talking about this sort of
this red scare
i'm coming back a new red scare of
mccarthyism because uh
i'm curious about what your thoughts are
because um
we seem like because i'm a zoomer so
a bunch of my uh friends they see flip
flaws and
unregulated capitalism and so uh
we're seeing like you know the
scientists saying like oh liberal
schools are uh
indoctrinating children in reality i
don't think that because
um my school like even like i live in
los angeles so
my college allows like republican
uh like clubs and stuff but then if you
do a socialist club
it's like oh that's way too extreme so i
just wanna so wait are you are you
saying that
your school shut down a socialist club
on campus uh
uh no like any sort of any not my school
because uh we're
democratic socialists they're allowed
but like if they say like
communist or like any like sway if they
don't have like democrat
they would like kind of they would label
it as like an extreme
in a way so your school has said that
communist groups would not be allowed
uh they never explicitly say that but
some but there
the teachers kind of don't like it
they don't know the teachers don't like
it so okay i
i'm let's not let's step back from that
just a little bit because it's not
it that that piece isn't making a whole
lot of sense to me when you say
a new red scare you're you're basically
just saying
that the right is going to play up fears
of communism and socialism invading the
united states
yes this is not a reactionary that's
happening that's happening and
you're seeing it i mean listen part of
the reason it's happening is that over
the last 10 or so years
republicans have moved away completely
from policy there's no more policy i
mean think to think think
cpac this past weekend there was no
discussion of policy beyond just very
vague
like we just need guns in more places we
can't make people get vaccines
we got to keep people from getting
indoctrinated there's no positive
proposal
proposal about how to deliver health
care etc
so what do you replace it with you
replace it with scare rhetoric about the
other side and
part of it is the sort of communism
socialism stuff
and you know let's just be really honest
about this i'm not a communist i'm not a
socialist i don't want the u.s to be a
communist or socialist country
but i recognize that there's no
immediate risk of that at all there's no
communists or socialists in positions of
power
joe biden is a capitalist and you know
we we've just got to be honest about
that but it's not surprising
that in the absence of policy they go to
fear-mongering rhetoric
yeah so do you think it would be like
the to the extreme of mccarthyism at
that time or it's just going to be like
you know what they're doing
kind of right now everything is so
different today than it was during the
mccarthy era that no i don't think it's
the same thing
i think it's probably reductive and
inaccurate to say it's a new mccarthyism
we have something going on right now
that's
disgusting and horrible but it's not
mccarthyism no i wouldn't say that
oh okay um yeah i was just curious
because um a second thought video
came out and i thought it was it said
like a new red scare i thought that it
had some pretty good information so
um yeah i mean listen i don't have any
problem with people calling it a new red
scare
it probably gets clicks it's something
people might identify with in practice i
think we have sort of its own thing
where
there was a different the reason that
it's happening now is a republican party
that is completely abandoned
abandoned even pretending to care about
policy and they're filling the void with
fear
the motivations for the mccarthy era
were different the rhetoric may be
similar though that i will concede
oh okay yeah uh thank you so much david
my pleasure
uh take care you too very much
appreciate the call
let's go to a quick break and we will be
back with much more
right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show so this is a story
that is notable but it's notable for
different reasons than
most of the people who are reacting to
it think it's notable for
one of donald trump's election fraud
lawyers jenna ellis quit the republican
party
live on her television program yesterday
she hosts a show called
the truth on real america's voice i
don't know what that is either but
that's what it is that's what it's
called
and on that show yesterday she said
she's out
she's out of the republican party until
further notice
but why is she out because as far as
she's concerned the republican party
isn't crazy enough
the republican party isn't fighting hard
enough
to argue that donald trump actually won
the 2020 election
and so she's leaving now i'll explain
more in a second but let's first look at
the clip
all of them including ronna mcdaniel
should resign now
until they do as of today i am resigning
from the party
i am changing my voter registration and
i am no longer a republican
until the party decides that it wants to
be conservative again
even if i stand alone for the truth i
will stand for the truth
a compromised corrupted majority is not
a majority
worth being a part of if we genuinely
want to create a more perfect union
we have to stand up for our principles
against the corrupted machine
of self-serving politicians in
washington so what is this all about
jenna ellis is quitting because some
emails leaked where a top
republican national committee lawyer
criticizes what jenna ellis was doing
vis-a-vis election fraud with rudy
giuliani and the whole lot of them
in the november election and in the
months following it and jenna doesn't
like it jen is personally insulted
there actually were some people in the
republican party who are still
republicans and i don't agree with them
on policy but there were some
republicans in the republican party that
realized
after the 2020 election that joe biden
won
donald trump lost that's it and that
when jenna ellis and rudy giuliani
and sydney powell were going around the
country
holding these hearings flying around the
country passing covet among themselves
remember jenna got it rudy got it
rudy got it etc claiming these
conspiracies
about there were massive dumps in the
middle of the night and there was a van
with food and all of this stuff there
were some republicans including people
like ronna mcdaniel and others in the
republican party who said
we look ridiculous we're becoming a you
know we're becoming an
even bigger laughing stock they would
say it's just we're not looking good
they were already a laughingstock stock
it was becoming a bigger one
and jenna ellis is mad that not
everybody
was on board with her election
conspiracy theories
and so she's quitting the republican
party in protest
this isn't a principle than moral
republicans saying
the party has abandoned me i will no
longer vote for republicans
i am going to the democratic party or
i'm moving to the left that that's not
what this is
it's someone saying the party isn't
nutty
enough i'm too nutty essentially for the
republican party
and so i'm leaving and here she is in a
painfully long-winded
clip explaining more about why she's
doing this
so jenna why would you want to stay
in the republican party you uh doesn't
sound like you uh have a home there and
i heard
i was just passed a note that you might
have an announcement to make regarding
your affiliation as a republican
yes well i also announced today that i
am leaving the republican party until
the republican party comes back home to
conservatives
i will stand up and champion truth
conservative principles
our declaration of independence as
america's charter and the u.s
constitution but i will not stand and
abide by a party
that says that we have to support
everything that comes under the banner
of
r even though it's not conservative for
rana for example to tweet
um in affirmation of pride month for
this whole infrastructure bill for what
mitch mcconnell
said about president trump in the
aftermath of the second impeachment hoax
all of these things are not conserving
our principles
of liberty and justice for all they're
not conserving our constitution
so i'm not going to stand by and support
a party that doesn't support my values
and if
every single registered republican who's
a true conservative demands of the
republican party
okay so at some point i have to just cut
it i mean this went on for several more
minutes not not a concise explanation
but
all that stuff about the constitution
and all of what she's saying what she
means is not everyone at the republican
party is on board
with my embarrassing and flaccid
attempts to steal the election
and i'm mad that they thought what i was
doing didn't make any sense
so the bigger story here is is this
going to develop into a bigger
schism or rift in the republican party
which could damage them in 2022
which i would love it's too early to
tell
remember that jenna ellis is in the
pro-trump side of the party
people like ronna mcdaniel i guess
they're sort of like trump agnostic
i think mcdaniel realizes if the party's
voters are with trump
the leadership probably needs to stick
with trump too
but she seems to realize trump is sort
of a cartoon so unless it's really clear
that the voters are abandoning trump i
don't think
this fracture in the party is going to
become serious and as you know if you've
been watching the show for the last few
weeks
republican voters are overwhelmingly
with donald trump right now now what
would be interesting
this is sort of a smaller question than
will the party completely crack into
what what's an interesting question to
consider is whether there will be a real
fight
as to whether the 2022 campaigns of
these of republicans up for re-election
will be run on 2020 was stolen by
democrats and joe biden that's one way
they could run in 2022.
they could run on policy
right or they could run on you know
democrats
or communists and joe biden's a marxist
and that's really really bad
my instinct is that trump and the
national media figures
are going to keep pushing the election
was stolen and that's why we need to win
2022 narrative
but i think republicans at the local
level at least many of them
are going to go with not policy no
they're not going to go with policies
done for this party
local republicans or at least
republicans
that have to focus on how they talk
about the election
in their district with their
constituents are going to go with
communism and is bad and democrats you
know gas prices
and marxism and spend spent spend that
type of thing
they've totally abandoned policy um and
that would be
an interesting thing to see in 2022 do
they run on the
election was stolen or do they run on
we've got to stop this communism which
of course doesn't exist
i think it will be the latter this is
really amazing
this will really be as far as i know
this
is really the final cpac segment for the
week okay so just
uh bear that in mind we covered cpac
we covered the speeches we covered
trump's lie riddled speech from sunday
already i'm not doing that again
it was brought to my attention that on
fox news
as soon as donald trump started telling
his election lies during his speech
fox put up a disclaimer clearly meant to
avoid another
potential lawsuit over donald trump's
obviously demonstrably false claims
about who won the 2020 election the
disclaimer that popped up on the screen
on fox news when trump started lying
about who won
said quote the voting system companies
have denied
the various allegations made by
president trump and his counsel
regarding the 2020 election let's look
at and listen to a video
if you're not watching as soon as trump
starts telling the lies
the disclaimer pops up on the screen on
election night we did
so much better than they ever thought in
their wildest imagination
that they just said the hell with it let
it go
what they did what they did i'm also
leading
in the polls against harris because not
a lot of people think that joe's going
to be running but you
never know this is a strange world
and everyone else is going to run on the
radical left whether it's
on the democrat side or the re i love my
republicans but
we're really kicking their ass too but
we love them
but we like it because they're friends
of ours right so it's okay i think we
can say that affectionately
no they're great they're great and
they're working hard that is really
something else
but it's also relevant that the
disclaimer is
pathetically weak the voting system
companies
have denied the allegations of trump
about the election
it's not just the voting system
companies have denied it there is no
evidence for it 60 lawsuits have been
thrown out
there have been audits and re-audits and
so-called audits and hearings and
re-hearings
and there should be uh a statement that
says there is
no evidence whatsoever of election fraud
that would impact the results in even a
single
state so on the one hand it's notable
that fox news now that they are under
lawsuit from dominion and we'll get to
that in a second
they're putting up this disclaimer as
soon as trump starts lying but then the
other part of this the other side of
this is
the disclaimer is pathetically weak it's
a disclaimer that basically puts
trump's claims of fraud and dominion's
denials of fraud
on the same footing right it's okay so
trump is claiming fraud and dominion
voting systems
has denied the fraud it's kind of like a
both sides thing fox news is saying
we're telling you what each side is
saying and that's it but if you do news
you should be able to say there is
absolutely no evidence of what donald
trump
is claiming here it's not just trump
claims and dominion denies
and in fact it's not just fear
of lawsuits that's at play fox news is
being sued
fox news is being sued by dominion
voting systems
and not only that not only that in this
very same lawsuit just a few days ago
dominion voting systems has subpoenaed
rudy giuliani
sydney powell and my pillow ceo
mike lindell in that very lawsuit so
this is very
actively very real but it's still
a really weak disclaimer if fox news had
guts
or any concern for journalistic
integrity
they would say the election was won
fairly by president biden
contrary to donald trump's claims the
election was won fairly by joe biden
there is
no evidence at all that supports donald
trump's claims
instead they do this pathetic flaccid
weak disclaimer but the fact that
they're doing it at all we know why
it's because of what's going on legally
at this point in time
we're following the lawsuit there's been
no real news on it um
recently they've sent these subpoenas to
rudy sydney powell and mike lindell we
don't know
what's actually going to happen as far
as their involvement in the suit goes
but
we will keep you posted about it but fox
news doing the absolute
minimum it's sort of like a back page
uh retraction that nobody sees but the
newspaper
hopes clears them legally that's what
fox news is doing here
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
i have to tell you um i'm worried
that i am just terrible at communicating
with my audience and what i mean by that
is
um sometimes i think i'm being clear
about what i'm saying
and then i get a voicemail like this one
and i start wondering
what the hell is going on with my
communication skills maybe i really
can't express myself effectively this is
related to my story
last week about what's going on in haiti
and explaining
some of the racist analyses of the
economic differences between haiti and
the dominican republic
and then i got this voicemail take a
listen
david sir sir
talking about man and i'm talking about
the segment that you did in regards to
haiti
yeah and the dominican republic okay
saying that
we come from a european descent
which i absolutely disagree being
dominican from the dominican born and
raised in the dominican
matter of fact if you pay attention
to any sports that includes dominican
players
most of the players that you will see
are not of
european descent right we have
old range of colors when it comes to
people we have black
we have white and we have a lot of
in-betweens
right and for the most part
we are compromised in in the population
i'm talking about
of people that are either of dark skin
color
listen what i explained last week
was for people who may be aware that
haiti and the dominican republic share
an island the island of espanola
but haiti is significantly worse off
economically
i wanted people to know that there is a
very common racist story that's told
about why the dominican republic is
better off than haiti
the story that the racists tell is
haiti is mostly people of african origin
black people whereas the dominican
republic
is much more significantly comprised of
what we would call
latino and european origin meaning white
people now the actual breakdown
is that haiti is almost completely
african
whereas the dominican republic is only
11 african
16 white slash what we would call
european
and 72 percent mix which includes
european and other things okay i wasn't
saying
the dominican republic is a european
country
i was explaining that the truth about
the disparities between haiti and the
dominican republic
are quite complex and they relate to
geography
they relate to weather they relate to
deforestation
and that jared diamond has written a lot
about this that's the real story
the wrong story is that there are people
who like to just say
haiti's worse off because it's mostly
black people
and the dominican republic is not and
that's true but
am i really i mean should i quit is
there a
i i feel i don't know if it's me or it's
somebody else
but i feel like i am not i must not be
communicating effectively as i was
trying to say this is the story that's
told
it's a wrong story okay let's move on
we have a great bonus show for you today
the world health organization is warning
against mixing and matching coveted
vaccines but many people are doing it
and i know people in fact that have done
this
we will also talk about the gavin
newsome recall in california
and we will talk about millennials
living paycheck to paycheck
on over one hundred thousand dollars a
year okay all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show don't miss it sign
up at joinpakman.com
to get instant access and i will see you
then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman